Now, one thing that's important about
the horizon is that the horizon isn't
just something you make up, right?
The horizon actually depends upon
things like your discount factor.
And if you have a very small
discount factor then so
far out in the future it doesn't
matter what's happening anyway.
And so you can do better.
But if you have a reasonable
discount factor then you're going to
have to look pretty far in
the future to get a good estimate
of taking a particular action
in a particular state.
>> Okay, makes sense.
>> Right.
So this is both good and bad, right?
Monte Carlo is kind of neat because
it's sort of neat on its own.
It's very useful,
it's one way of dealing with scale.
It's completely compatible with
options and other things that we know.
It has a bunch of dials in it, that we
can play with that sort of help us.
And that we might be able to take cool
advantage of, but you still need lots
and lots and lots and lots of samples in
order to make it work, which is true for
any Monte Carlo method.
>> So is there a sense in which
we traded, in big states basis,
we traded being exponential in
the number of state features say?
For instead exponential in
the size of their horizon?
>> Yeah and the trade off is, I mean
it's right here, I suppose this is our
trade off and you're right and
that makes sense, right?
Before with the kind of algorithms,
that we used before, you visit all
the states, you back up information
about them and so on and so forth.
So that clearly has to depend
upon the number of states.
Here, we're not worrying about the
states, what we're doing is we're just
looking forward into the future
by doing simulation.
And so every single time we have
to look forward into the future,
we have to look forward into the future.
And perhaps we have to look
forward very far into the future.
And somehow, because we're doing
this kind of Monte Carlo thing,
we're doing kind of, I don't know,
like a almost a non-parametric
estimate of whatever the true
transition model is, that's going to
require lots and lots of states.
And lots and lots of samples,
and more and
more samples the further out
into the future that we go.
So we are going to be trading that off.
We're always trading off kind of space
versus time in a particular way, and
here the space is
represented by the states.
As opposed to the time,
which is represented by how far
out you're going to search.
>> That's nice.
>> Thank you.